we have a new generation of young people
they're coming into the workforce
they're coming into the marketplace and
in their culture is the new culture of
work at their fingertips they have
better tools than exist in some of our
most sophisticated corporations and if
there's a real danger that companies
will come out of this recession
demographically sort of looking like
Italy I don't be confused you know I
love Italy food people wine culture and
so on but the demographics of Italy it's
a country with a lot of old people and
not a lot of young people Japan's even
worse actually they have old people and
restrictive immigration policy so you
don't want to emerge from the recession
without with a company of old people
because you're in deep trouble you'll be
unable to make the big changes to your
business model and strategy enabled by
the internet that young people are
energizing within our corporations
young people are in the workforce the
bright-eyed bushy-tailed what do we do
we stick them in a cubicle supervised
and treat them like Dilbert and rather
than embracing their tools like social
networks and blogs and wiki's and jams
and so on we ban them we do the opposite
of what we should do and banning
Facebook is a totally dysfunctional
thing to do now if employees are wasting
their time on Facebook that's an
opportunity to talk about about real
issues one youngster for my book grown
up digital I asked I asked him 27 years
old works for US federal agency what was
the effect of banding Facebook and he
said it was the single most demoralizing
thing the management has ever done it
said we don't understand your tools we
don't understand you we don't get
collaboration and we don't trust you so
take a page from best buy the CEO there
Brad Anderson says my job is not just to
make decisions it's to create the
conditions whereby people can
self-organize to create value and I says
the most important people in this
company or the Blueshirts the young
people work in the stores tens of
thousands of them their closest to our
customer most like our customer and in
their culture is the 21st century best
buy and between them and me are layers
and layers of management trying to
prevent them from changing the company
so he says my job is to give them a
license to self-organize so to your
point they self organized a 25,000 of
them created social network called blue
shirt nation they feel engaged they
collaborate they talk about things they
share problems but rather than a sort of
command and control hierarchy they have
a networked organization where where
where people use these powerful new
tools for collaboration to have a sense
of ownership in the company and that's
even more important in tough times like
this
you